[Music]
hello everybody welcome to these games
of the week lecture my name is pepper
cuenca i am anna finest grandmaster
happy to be here with all of you and
today we're gonna check a game that
magnus carlsen the current world
champion played against Ganguly in the
Isle of Man tournament you know why this
tournament is so important
exactly so the first I mean the winner
of this tournament qualifies for the
candidates in the candidates you know
that eight players are playing and the
one who wins the candidate with
candidates sorry will face Magnus
Carlsen in the World Championship so
Magnus and Fabiano Caruana both of them
are playing in this tournament even
though they cannot qualify of course
because Magnus is the current champion
and Fabiano Caruana has a spot in the
candidates since he was the last
Challenger of Magnus Carlsen
do you know Ganguly Indian player really
strong
he beat me I think he beat me four times
he fit me four times in the rapid World
Championship in Berlin in the Spanish
league twice I think so I'm having
nightmares because because in one of
those games I was completely winning
with a banker gambit but he managed to
beat me and okay so he's super strong
per year 26:58 rating and the game was
really really interesting so why don't
we start with it and remember guys in
the youtube channels you can ask me
anything I got you here in my phone so I
can answer your questions
okay so efore was played by Magnus
Carlsen c5 Sicilian defence Knight f3 d6
and here Magnus in many many of these
games he has gone for this Bishop b5
which is more positional so after Bishop
b5 there are different approaches for
black here you can play in 96 Bishop d7
or 97 for example of the bishops d7
takes Queen takes and c4 you want to
reach some sort of Meraki structure with
the white pieces you want to go
93 and d4 for example in the game
between I think magnus carlsen was
playing this against Kovalenko could be
in this Isle of Man tournament so knight
c6 Knight c3 and Magnus went for a 5
where later he went for Bishop e7 Bishop
d8 Knight d7 if I remember correctly
Maximus Magnus Magnus yeah he was black
and he played this language a 5 which is
very interesting it looks like this
bishop is terrible but then he managed
to find a way for this Bishop through d8
and then probably later with by a 5 ok
this is another whole story because in
this game magnums decide to go for the
open Sicilian with d4 so C takes d4 and
here the main line is after Knight takes
d4 also Queen takes d4 is possible
because of the knight c6 you want to
continue with Bishop b5 pinning this
night and then again you want to develop
your pieces and then go long castle but
I know sorry Knight takes d4 Knight f6
Knight c3 and here you have many
possibilities how this is called after
g6 the dragon and after is 6
Schaben ingen or something like that
it's a Dutch warrior
I don't know how to pronounce that and
after knight c6 classical Sicilian and
in this game Magnus sorry Ganguly
decided to go for a 6 which is called
the knight of one of the most
complicated
Sicilians I would say lot of tactics
going on and then the fury has has been
developed a lot here in the last year's
so here there are many possibilities for
white you can play Bishop g5 going for
one of the most sharpest lines in the
neither of you can play Bishop e2 Bishop
a4 which of III going for the English
attack also f3 straight away for and h3
h3 has been very trendy in the last
year's
is rather simple you want to go g4 in
the next moves and then attack fast on
the kingside I'm here again different
alternatives for black you can play
Nexus 6 is 6 in order to strike in the
center with d5 and in this game black
played a fine of course this is very
natural in the night off this square is
going to be weak but then you win a
temple because this Knight has to
retreat so where would you go now with
the night with this knight on d4 Knight
b3 this is what actually Magnus played
in the game there's another may move
here okay 93 doesn't make so much sense
95 the problem with this Knight a5 is
that after Bishop takes pawn takes d5
then black gets the center and also you
can even go d5 straight away I guess in
this position so Knight a5 sorts of
possible of course the other move is 92
and this is the main line because
White's idea is to go g4 then Bishop g2
and then the knight on g3 is doing a
fantastic job because it protects efore
and in many variations you want to jump
to f5 right so black backs idea in the
last years has been to go h5 here in
order to stop g4 and then here you have
two approaches you you can play Bishop
g5 fighting straight away for the D Phi
squared you can go g3 okay but in the
game Magnus went for Knight b3 and here
to may moves Bishop e7 or Bishop e6 both
natural Ganguly decided to go for Bishop
e7 I'm now Magnus
continuing with the spirit of this line
he went for g4 right so aiming to go g5
when it's on space in the queenside so
how do you stop g5
yeah eight six so you don't need to stop
that move but then it's interesting
because now white will struggle to play
g5 but you want to go h4 first of all is
that g4 is hanging and even though if
you manage to protect somehow g4 and
then play eight four it's not gonna be
easy to play g5 because after this trade
then the Rubin h1 will be hanging so
white would need like a lot of Chimpy to
strike with this g5 okay so eight six
was played and now Magnus went for
Bishop e3 now this move is more flexible
than going straight away for Bishop g2
because in many variations maybe you
want to keep this Bishop on e - you
still don't know and with Bishop e3 and
then Queen d2 the percentage more
flexible because you have not decided
yet how to castle you can go long castle
you can go short castle depending on the
situation and here there are many many
interesting moves b5 Bishop e6 and in
the game ganguly decided to go for
Knight B to d7 we have to say that this
knight normally in the night off is
better place on d7 than on c6 because
from d7 after some b5 moves you can jump
to b6 and then to c4 where you actually
are attacking this bishop on e3 and also
targeting the b2 phone so after Knight B
to d7 Magnus went for a for profit Laxus
against b5 and now how do you develop
this bishop from c 8b 6
and also you are stopping a5 ideas right
so basics was played by Ganguly how do
you continue if you want to push your
pawns here also we have to take in
account that this Bishop is gonna put
pressure on e4 right away in the next
movement
yeah so f3 is this this is what Magnus
played makes a lot of sense because you
reinforce the center with this 4 point
and now you want to
with 84 and g5 and here incredibly
Ganguly played Queen c7 which is
incredibly considered like a small
mistake
sorry there's nothing wrong with Bishop
in seven and actually it was the best
move according to the engines let's try
to explain why so Bishop e7 blacks idea
after Queen d2 what do you think what do
you think it's blacks idea you want to
go along Castle here yeah yeah but I
mean what's blacks idea in the b5
jus-just blunder upon 8585 actually
helps white because now g5 is easier to
play so I just go a g5 and then I gain
more control over the DD v square okay
this is very tough this is very what do
you say
d5 this this was actually blacks engines
idea so this was the the way to equalize
the game and now what happens if I take
with my pawn
okay 95 I think I can take everything
take take and then Bishop c4 and then I
managed to protect this guy in d5 and
then white is gonna enjoy fantastic
advantage so put pressure my d5 pawn
sorry
9 f8 again I can play for example rook
t1 exactly Bishop b4 that's actually it
takes d5 is a bad move because after
Bishop b4 you're going to capture this
at this point on d5 and in this central
pawn falls then black would be much much
better
so after defy do you have to take with
the knight Knight takes d5 Knight takes
d5 it takes d5 and now yes
Bishop a5 that's it
that's illegal yeah you want a jam here
you want to get my queen or it
yeah Bishop H for right now you said
Bishop g5 85 I mean but yeah but you
wanted to come here yeah you should page
4 because now or maybe you didn't with
the porn okay you wanted to go a 5 here
all right
that's interesting but okay you give me
like a free tempo and now this P Phi
square could be interesting for me I
could develop this Bishop over there
then you are never threatening Bishop
before because I can just meet that with
c3 right so the idea here is to go
Bishop 8 4 and now after Bishop f2 only
move do you want to go Bishop g5 and
again you go P should be 3 I'm happy
with that
with the drone and you move the Queen
let's say I can play Knight f6 and then
again this point is gonna suffer this a
lot of compensation going on here you
can go short castle II for open Sun
lines this game is got actually it's not
it's not legal even to castle year
on the queenside and then it's gonna be
tough to castle on the cane side as well
so this was the best idea according to
the engines really tough to say in over
the board I mean if you don't know the
position
so instead Ganguly played Queen c7 which
looks extremely natural to me and now
what do you think Magnus Carlsen played
here Queen d2 that's a natural move a
more direct approach maybe to attack h4
okay Queen d2 it's it's perfectly fine
but Magnus decided to go for eight four
and here again Bishop d7 look more
natural but now here Ganguly comes up
with this plan with 9 f8 okay he wants
to put the bishop on e6 and now this
knife could come to g6 at some point and
then try to jump to f4 now we want to
play g5 what do we have to do because if
we play g5 straight away then black
takes and then our rook on h1 is hanging
so we had to take with the bishop on g5
and this is not ideal because what we
want to do is to kick this knight from
Essex to gain some control on d5 so
after net f8 root g1 exactly so next
move is going to be
g5 and then we have some control on the
d5 square Bishop e6 as you can see here
in the knight of a lot of the moves are
played in order to fight for these t5
squared right g5 h takes H takes 97 and
now what do we play
where are your candidates move oops
yet 95 that's always a move that we have
to consider Queen d2 perfect some other
moves it should be - okay sorry
85 that's interesting as well okay but
f4 it's also interesting
I mean it's risky because we have our
kin in the center so maybe we have to
castle first and then try to push this
this point right okay but Magnus went 95
and now this is a key moment actually
for black so do we take on d5 or do we
move do we move the Queen
if you take on d5 you're losing a white
square
yeah which is very very important in
this position yeah
the bishop one is six but okay yeah okay
if you decide to take with the bishop
now how do you recapture the five with a
pony with the Queen with the Queen
always most of the times there are many
positions in the neither of where you
take with the pawn because there are so
95 and 96 ideas yeah I mean no actually
this rook has a problem because ASIC is
hanging so you go to c8 yeah so for
example Luke 1/7 of what do you play
another 96
f or g 6g 6 looks crushing yeah so
you're gonna destroy this black screen
now there's no way of stopping G takes
and then you take here then Queen e6
just with the game alright so after
Bishop d5 Queen 65 Black is in real
trouble so that's why after Knight d5
we've got to do something else yeah
Queen V Salmons you say looks natural
Quincy 6 in the game can ganguly when
Queen c6 I cannot see a problem jet
after this move Queen b7 I think the
reason bringing the Queen to c6 is that
you are also protecting d6 which could
be week after Sun trade some on e7 okay
so now after Queen c6 do we take an 87
or not
yeah I like the knight on d5 so I mean
if we take on e7 I think blacks fine
because it's not easy to Castle now
because we got this a four point also
there is this Bishop b3 also all the
time whenever we want to go a long
castle here and our kin will will land
on c1 we're gonna have struggle here and
then the knight on b3 is not a good
piece blacks plan is very very simple
you wanna go knack g6 maybe activate
this rook maybe also bring in another
route to the C file and looks good for
black so that's why Magnus didn't go 497
and instead he went for Queen d2 this
looks very very natural so what do we
play now with the black pieces
knock g6 looks like the most natural
move to me this night is doing nothing
here and then from g6 do control f4 I'm
not so sure you want to go along castle
as your castle because I think I'm gonna
make you on the age 5 dick but the knife
has to come to g6 right on f8 is doing
basically nothing
okay so Magnus wanted to go alone castle
but there could be some troubles in the
future with the a for porn
okay still you don't have real troubles
because there's nag c7 but Magnus decide
to you know do something with this a for
porn and then he pushed this pawn to a5
now what would you play with the black
pieces do you take this phone do you
play b5 yeah exactly it's attacked by
the knight bishop and the pawn so you
got to do something about this phone
sorry b5 looks good how about B takes a
5 you like this move
yeah Queen takes or even a better move
Knight takes with a temple yeah then the
screen where's is this Queen going I
don't know I don't even see a square
maybe CA there's something this looks
really really sad and as you say the a61
it's gonna be attack easily sorry so
taking on a5 doesn't look like the best
idea and as you said the pony's attacks
attacks are three times so I think the
best try is what Ganguly did in the game
so you close the position here and then
you still have the C file in case white
wants to go for long castle as Magnus
did in the game so long castle and now
normal moves here with the black pieces
rook c8 pouring pressure on the c2 pawn
and here there is a move that I 99% of
the times play in this kind of Sicilians
that exactly wait when you don't know
what to do just move the Queen away to
be one here the gain is safer doesn't
see
one for sure and then okay you say pass
and we'll see what we do in the next in
the next move
okay so here Knight c5 was played and
again now we have a tough decision do we
take on c5 it's closing the C file but
it's also improving black structure
right because d6 one was weak
Knight see when it's a really it's a
passive move I don't know if it's any
good but I wouldn't consider like my
first choice here it's interesting
because you wanna maybe go 92 and 93 or
some stuff like that but it doesn't
smell well you know so I mean we have
two options here either we take on c5 or
we improve the rest or of our Antebellum
pieces we should be - this is what
Magnus played actually in the game I
think Knight takes e5 there's nothing
wrong with this move
you can play also after the D takes you
can play moves like c4 and then you have
a monster here in d5 so black can be
worse I mean black sorry white why it
should be a little bit better here but
Magnus okay decided to go Bishop b2 and
then he asks ganguly you want to take on
b3 all right if you take on b3 then my
pawn structure will be ruined but then
at the same time I got this e-file now
for my rook for my rooks now I can't
fight for the C file - and then I got
this b6 square so taking out on b3 it's
not that clear so any moves for black
here
9a for interesting very very interesting
this night a for now hmm
sorry there's no threat
Roxy wine could be an idea yes also
night before but I think you got queen
bee 7 and nothing happens Mary first is
interesting there's not thread of an
area for but night that's still there
and then it could be something going on
so all the moves of luck I mean this
Bishop here on e7 we said ok white is
not going to take it but there's always
this threat of night tech c7 exactly so
Bishop d8 is actually a good move do you
cover b6 it's not a threat because a5 is
protected but it could be a threat in
the future and now you ask why what he
wants to do and then here Magnus decides
to go all in he takes on c5 and now he
tries to open the position how Knight b6
I think this Bishop takes me six and
this is just a pawn up for black right
so pon takes and Queen b6
see for it's a move but then after
before be careful because you're a
five-point is gonna struggle so Magnus
decided to go for f4 good move and
basically he's forcing black to take on
f4 because otherwise f5 is gonna come
winning the game right and so ETA x f4
was played and now how do we take this
pawn with the night with the bishop
yeah still it's not clear how this
Bishop is getting active he could get
active but I mean I loved this knight on
d5 and it's much better than this night
on g6 so if we take with a knight I
guess black to take here on f4 it looks
to me that black position is not that
bad
you can play moves like the porn here I
mean it could be extremely dangerous
taking this pawn
maybe Bishop d3 and g6 and then rook e1
but I mean if I play something like
Bishop e7 or even before now before
there is Queen d6 maybe but Bishop e7
first covering g6 and then asking what
you want to do it you play g6 I go f6
and then I close the position of course
I think white should be a little bit
better but ruk h1 could be played that's
move and now maybe this move is is legal
right sure castle but then you're gonna
get checkmate it over there so probably
I have to go rook to e8 or drugged f8
and still not so clear right so that's
why Magnus decided to take with the
bishop and the first question that comes
to my mind is can block take that bishop
or not is it a good idea to take that
bishop from F for winning the bishop
you like trading pieces okay so night
xf4 is actually a bad move because now
there are so many threats after night of
four can you see the threats for example
if I play Bishop e7 what will you play
96 and then if Queen takes Bishop g4
when in the game already
so not only 96 but also some g6 ideas 96
I'm there's not actually no way of
stopping 90s and 96 here in this
position right do you see a way I don't
see a way so if you go to d7 I don't
know but there has to be something for
sure here at least I can go g6 yeah if v
is 6 g6 Bishop f3 Bishop g4 rookie want
looks crushing and then actually you are
not able to to castle short side because
as we said like the age file is open and
we're gonna get checkmated in years so
that's why Ganguly decided to go for
Bishop e7 now and what do we do
what are your candidates moves Knight b6
and I take c7 bishop g3 you like 97 yep
that's a natural move this actually what
Magnus played that's a key exactly I
mean if we go Knight b6 here probably
route d8 it's not that clear because
also you have to pay attention to this
guy on f4 so let's say queen III now not
so sure it looks still dangerous for
black but maybe I could take now an f4
and queen takes and there are not so
many threats now look solid for black
still dangerous but I could try to
create some counter play don't know
maybe c4 something like that and I don't
see a direct threat here against black
skin so in the game Magnus took on e7
and Ganguly decided to take with the
king
covering g6
is it covered it's not covered right so
we could put a piece on the d6 square
and this is where actually Magnus dip
Bishop g6 now the King has to go back to
EA there are no possibilities of
castling right now because black move
the King twice and yeah if I'm
responsible that's right
Bishop f3 more moves we gotta be a
little bit careful because if we for
example play Bishop every then after
rook t8 is not clear how you're gonna
unpin because if are still not possible
because f3 is hanging so we gotta be a
little bit careful here in this position
yeah
Queen c3 it's a really interesting move
this is actually what macros played I
mean just a direct threat against g7 and
then they're not route d8 ideas now I
will be able to remove my Bishop and
then if we play e5 straight away I guess
black can't play rook h2 now this ruckus
trick is extremely active you can never
play rook h1 because the Queen is
covering also D Square and sorry and
then you are threatening many ideas here
with a black maybe Bishop c4 Queen efore
as you say so it could be tricky
suddenly so that's why Magnus plays
Queen c3 and now how we gonna protect
this g7 bomb we're gonna play a strange
move here roof g8 or Route 87 there's no
other way because you cannot go Tina Fey
it's illegal move so in the game Luke 8
7 was played keeping the options of
going route h1 or route gates to at some
point activating this rook so I prefer
route 8 7 that rather than rook GA
because the Dragoon g8 is just a passive
piece right an 8 7 it has the chance of
getting active at some point right ok
Magnus said you know what I did my job
but this bishop so I'm just gonna
retreat it and now what are we
threatening with this bishop GC root d6
exactly exactly
look this yeah rook d8 I mean we can
trade rooks and then bring the other one
and then finally penetrate on these six
so here there is a question that has to
come to our minds is Queenie for
possible because it looks freaks risky
but in in again we have to calculate
everything because we cannot give pre
material without knowing what's going on
Bishop f3 Bishop d3
I mean after Bishop f3 there could be a
move here
Queen C for probably Black's loose in -
yeah Queen takes e4 b should take C for
Bishop e7 that looks crushing also shot
Bishop e3 looks good
yeah Bishop e3 looks really good but
maybe I got this move Queen a 4 B 3 yeah
this looks like this looks very very
good
also Bishop d3 is very natural because
if we go to let's say c6 now for C moves
captures checks on threats and if F
takes yeah that's there is a an even
more direct approach here d6 only move
Queenie 4 and now rook e1 and black
prescience so that's why black couldn't
take this phone on e4 and instead
ganguly went for b4
what do you think Magnus played here
Queen d2 and if I play Queen a 4 B 3 can
I take this guy here and then will be to
give me that oh the bishop is covered I
didn't see this mmm so Queen d2 let me
think
Queen a 4 BC I can play Queen a5 here
b3 yes b3 that could be important now
still should be good for for white but
could be dangerous right we need to
allow Sun constantly
hey buddy are you doing okay
you guess you're good
alright so before so we don't want to
allow b3 for example so Queen d3 exactly
queen d3 actually is threatening to
things so the first one is what the pawn
on a six and what's the only move for
black here to protect that one route
kaid is a really passive move it's still
possible yeah okay after rook e8 what
will you play here with white there are
many ways yeah for sure but
Bishop f3 okay
hmm do you wanna go eat five right and
next move
very very interesting sorry
b3 again but then b3 I can just take
sorry
so c4 could be an idea but okay rookie
Rookie
ed is passive right so we have many in
many ways so c4 was played and now where
do we go you want to go Queen d6 so you
want to keep the Queen's in the board I
don't know what do you think
forces
please
sorry okay Queen d6 is the best move now
we're gonna analyze what happens here so
Queen d6
what are we threatening now we are
threatening actually the B for point you
said you wanted to go Queenie for here
okay let's see what can we do here
Queen a4 how about if I just take this
guy
b3 you want to go b3 and then BOOM ouch
that's an allow me all right now Queen
takes b3 yeah the position is looking
bad I don't know okay you want to go c3
here rook b8 rook basics or maybe a
better tries rookie six followed by
Queen is six check followed by Bishop b8
right so Queen a4 doesn't work
yeah I mean taking on these six how do
you take back with the Rooker Bishop
rook and then after root K eight
what's wrong with b3 that probably I can
take Roque six okay six or maybe I can
play beat XC to check intermediate move
kim taek's and now I don't know probably
White's winning because the bishop pair
is much stronger but it's not that clear
probably yeah maybe maybe White's
winning yeah but okay as you said rook
before rugby six is just simple yeah
because the system is requesting a log
off or restart of the computer would you
like to proceed no okay so now before it
is hanging right and after b3 how do we
win upon Drake takes and now this guy
falls right you see that cool okay so
that's why in the game Ganguly went
all-in
it took the pawn on e4
yeah and now it's an important moment
how do we continue yeah with the white
pieces Magnus is a genius and he saw a
beautiful combination yes
are you a genius like Magnus so what do
we play here now it's not me it's not me
not yet okay we're gonna be careful
because b3 is in the air yeah so you
want to go rook e1
okay how about b3 woof I saw I want to
take on d3 rookie for pond takes you're
playing with fire here you can't get
burned yeah really dangerous
so rookie want b3 here takes takes okay
let me think a little bit so take care
then this rook h1 later okay how about
if I D takes and then Queen you have to
take with the king
no it's in route d8 exactly here take
some now in a one here oh I got anyway I
don't even - I don't even need to
promote the Queen yeah boom rook
beautiful
so rook e1 is risky
Magnus found a better way exactly
when takes before runs into probably
Quinn taxi - yeah yeah yeah it's it's a
minute
actually the idea is to blunder the
bishop on II - but maybe I'll go b3
Magnus went for rook t4 yeah me neither
when I was checking the game I said yeah
so now can we take this Bishop on e2
probably now you know that the answer is
no but why and then if I if I go to f3
so rookie six yeah but then let's try to
understand what happens here I have got
night isse Evan and suddenly I got rook
h1 ideas group d12 when I go through t1
here okay but it's not checkmate don't
forget that I got this a seven squared
um you want to go ruk t8 and then take
away the Queen okay but for example here
I could go hmm is this women I don't
know I mean after Queen da I can just
take your queen so you are not
threatening checkmate
right
yeah but I mean you are a piece down so
you were out frettin something important
right so no there is a better a better
try here for white forcing moves
captures checks and threads by threads I
mean threatening the queen or checkmate
can we threaten the Queen here yes rook
e1 and now probably you saw already
after Queen s3 here you have to think
again checks captures and threats Queen
d7 even though I mean if you use this
method some moves at a first sight they
will look stupid to you but then maybe
they are not like this Queen d7 Queen d7
King f8 or now Queen texier we should
take CA the now rook da checkmate yeah I
can go back here okay so this is a
checkmate right so that's why Ganguly he
couldn't take the bishop on e2 and he
went Queen b7 Queen b7 in this position
so how do we continue with the white
pieces what do you think black is trying
to move in the next is trying to play in
the next move b3 all the moves
what what do you want to do with this
ruk ruk h1 trade this passive work for
this active route or at least dangerous
route route GD 1 then again rook h1
that's kind of the idea first Magnus
went for Queen b6 chasing the Queen now
do you think you can take them b6 no
because after pawn takes this Bishop is
covering b8 and b7 is going to follow
and black has to resign so that's why
Ganguly kept insisting with this Queen
a8 in this area what I learned to go
rook h1 and then you saw brilliantly the
idea that Magnus went for
ruk G to D one and now after rook ate
one Bishop II one and now this Bishop is
also coming to this diagonal taking this
pawn before and now things look very
very ugly for black in this position
actually Ganguly was in a desperate
situation and played night BB five sorry
now Bishop b4 was played roopd one group
t1 and queen c6 how do we continue Queen
d4 that's a move would you try it on c6
no right because the the black skin is
in a in a dangerous situation it's in
the center so I wouldn't take on c6 even
though I love end games you know because
I don't like risking as you said it's a
exactly I mean rook and games for
example are so tough are so complicated
right people tend to think like okay the
less species we have the easier the
easier is to play but these with
Brooking games not like that yeah for
example Aronian erroneous game
today's erroneous game was extremely
tough to understand the route gain game
against yeah rook d3 so against Chinese
player
okay so Bishop b4 Queen c6 and then we
got plenty of moves but for example
Queen III as magnet plate looks enough
because we're attacking this knight on
e5 and then Ganguly went Queen b5 so
protecting a5 attack eb4 c3 you want to
go c3
are you sure how about this move now I'm
not sure I mean probably you're still
winning but you're risking your life
here what happens after keen a1 I think
nothing yet but Queen a for Bishop a3
and still your survive but there's no
need for this
so play safe remove Bishop c3 exactly
you protect beat you
so this era is never gonna get open and
then how is black trading contemplate so
and you're also talking e5 so rook c5
was played and now there is a brilliant
move again from Magnus Carlsen
to finish the game
your site okay let's see if the other if
the others can figure it out
you win material in the next move the
next move yes yes
I mean after you play this move them
Black Bull struggle and then you'll get
some material for free you'll get a
piece for free what it's not easy
Queen Queen d4 route d5 and okay nothing
happens but you don't win anything
somebody I see somebody in the YouTube
channel
figure it out already Bishop Bishop e5
yeah but but then black gets a piece
back right after rook e5
yeah exactly they're not first that
Queen takes root really after all these
brilliant games you want to sacrifice
your queen for nothing you want to
finish it in brilliant style so can just
okay Luke h1 it's interesting of course
but it's not made yet this move wins
material you saw it
tell me be for crazy move you never
imagined like moving the pond just at
the big pond which is covering your kin
but now the thing is black can take and
percent because the queen is hanging and
then your threat is Queen takes e5 if
the rook moves then the night falls and
what happens after ninety seven you tell
me
rook d7 exactly and then Quincy five
wins so so actually Ganguly went for
ninety three gesture he was extremely
desperate so TC text III Luke T 5 and D
takes e4 and he resigned because after
route D one Bishop takes Queen C 4 you
are only giving me one check and then
after king c1 there's no more checks
okay you have a check on a three but
that's nothing I can always run away by
a d2 okay so this was madness game
against Ganguly and it was very
important because he caught me hail tau
because he managed to get 95 games
without losing and you know who's got
the record in the world like number of
games without losing in the top
tournaments in the Dingley rain you know
he's a Chinese player so he has hundred
games without losing I think Mac news
now is in 97 or 98 97 right so and he's
playing in Isle of Man so he can break
this record we'll see if this happens so
this concludes the lecture thank you for
coming and hope to see you probably next
time I come to same ways because this is
my last day here and coming back to
Spain thank you guys for coming
[Music]
you